Here's some foods I made today to make sure we have food for the week.
I cut my sourdough into eight equal pieces,
then shaped them into small English muffin rounds
and allowed them to rise for two hours before cooking them in a pan.
I had been sprouting walnuts for the past 24 hours,
so I rinse these and put them in the dehydrator to crisp up.
I washed some NYX minimalized corn that had been soaking all night
and made a big batch of fresh masa
using a Molino to grind the corn into a dough.
I made some pumpkin muffins which the kids loved,
but I wasn't happy with the texture,
so I'll be making these again soon.
I made some sourdough cinnamon rolls which had fermented overnight.
The dough was so nice and soft
and I spread cinnamon butter all over it before letting it rise again.
Then I spread a homemade cream cheese frosting over top.
I batched out two zucchini lasagnas.
These are low in carbs and high in protein.
Made a big batch of hamburger for quick snacks,
a garden fresh salad for quick lunches,
and a Mayo dressing. Pasture raised egg bites for protein on the go.
Ice start some leftover lard from cooking pasture raised bacon
by straining the particles out.
And then I made some sauerkraut.